in the lobby of Ramsey solutions John
and Teresa are with us hey how are you
how are you welcome welcome where do you
guys live Cincinnati Ohio welcome to
Nashville and I'm guessing you're here
to do your debt-free screen
finally very cool how much have you paid
off we prayed off of a hundred and fifty
thousand good and how long did that take
you four years Wow very quick making
what kind of money we start off about
120 and I'm up to about 150 now good for
you hundred and sixty one hundred and
fifty what do you do for a living I'm a
pharmacist cool very cool good for you
so I'm gonna guess the one hundred and
fifty thousand might have been some
student loans I had about eighty
thousand in student loans and my wife
had thirty and then we had two cars that
amounted around forty thousand or so
oh okay Wow alright so you had some
digging to do a lot so what happened
four years ago tell me your story how
did you decide to do this and what
happened well I grew up with a family
that a lot of people considers
financially wise and everything but they
still had a lot of that more for
business because they're farmers and
that's just the way they always live but
they never worried about the credit
cards always paid off the end of the
month no interest then they always talk
to me about things like that and I think
that made it so that when I did hear
about you write it in my last year
pharmacy school one of my preceptors
gave me your book and I read it and it
all made sense it clicked and I was like
as soon as we get through this school
we're hitting that we're gonna hit it
hard and that's what happened four years
ago mm-hmm
very cool so Teresa you were in
agreement then yes yes it was I didn't
grow up in a financially wise home I
grew up in a single-parent home and we
would just paycheck to paycheck but
getting together and getting things
going and him teaching me a lot about
money and not only starting financial
peace um we kind of let it at our church
and that learning more like oh this this
$25.00 sure it's gonna cost me you know
fifty dollars by the time I pay all the
interest off of it so just learning
those things that I didn't know growing
up was a large part of it and then why
pay them when I'll say even just
okay there you go I love it very cool so
you guys rolled up your sleeves what it
did just sell anything not really most
of that came from just working hard we
tried to hit the budget every month that
was probably one of our biggest
struggles is trying to make sure we were
hitting that budget every month we'd
start and then we'd stop and then we'd
start and stop and I know the first year
we weren't as committed to it and then
we actually led your class at our church
and once we did that
nothing like teaching something to make
you do it exactly we started and that
was the main part of doing it just
making sure that we we kept to it and
striving all the way we didn't have to
worry about selling too much we just
every month yeah for us is delayed
gratification like I want this right now
but it's better for us to wait and
better for us to you know save up the
cash for example our van is almost done
done we are it's got one little problem
after the other and it's still running
so I had to get in my mind for me that's
like my my child hauler with our five
kids it right I'm like I need to wait
because we can get something nicer and
then we can save and not have this
burden of debt over our heads so we are
now going to start saving it and try to
get something like that for cash yeah
you should be able to I mean you've
averaged 35 to 40,000 a year in debt
reduction yep so very well done and with
five kids yes Wow that's one thing I
wanted to say I know a lot of people
that get into debt that are looking for
adoption have they see this big mountain
of debt that they can run up $40,000 for
an adoption things like that two of our
kids are actually well ones adopted and
the others about to be and we started
down that private adoption road and we
probably sank five or six thousand
dollars into it and then we got into
looking at the foster care system and
we've adopted Khloe with no debt I mean
if anything were financially better off
because of going that right and JT's on
his way that way he's hopeful he'll be
done soon
and then there are risk there with the
heartache of possibly and then going
back to their biological parents but
there's there's also a great need there
too oh it's definitely one of those
things that we're passionate about and
we we really like this
I guess spread that message that you can
adopt without death and you can adopt
and actually be better off with then
most states have a stipend yeah tax-free
I mean there's all kinds of things you
can do now to help the foster care
system
yes trained on it yeah well
congratulations you guys and what a
wonderful way to build your family yeah
you guys are impressive
how does it feel that's great yet for me
I'm just like we're not doing much
different it's just what do you hear
when you're standing before your class
next time you teach the class and they
ask you you pay off on a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that seems so
overwhelming how did you do that what do
you tell them the keys are already
getting out of that contentment probably
the biggest one and then making sure
you're on that budget all the time
definitely will help I know when the
when we were hitting it all the time on
that budget it felt like we had that
raise I know people talk about that a
lot but it when you actually see and we
actually paid that much this month
compared to last month we didn't pay
nearly as much when we were running the
budget manage money just works harder
than it exactly and for me cash if if
you could just do cash and you see it
visibly going out of your hands and
you're you're losing that dollar like is
it worth it nope just put that back guys
whatever we were standing in the grocery
line several times and I said nope this
is out of our budget this is out of our
budget
cash budget nope this is all we have so
that's what the cash in our hand was
really a big mom worker for me to get to
visually see everything the envelope
system in conjunction with a well-run
budget made all the difference in the
world
yes very cool well thank you for leading
Financial Peace University and
congratulations from you guys are rock
stars very fun all right John and
Theresa from Cincinnati Ohio
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
paid off in four years making a hundred
and twenty to a hundred and fifty
thousand a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three -
why love it love it love it well done
you guys
man that's fabulous